[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisir avec vos
idées de sortie pour ce weekend Gabriel
on commence avec de la musique oui
Matilda avis aux fans de métal le
festival métalsphère revient dès
vendredi et jusqu'à samedi soir au
programme de jours de concert dédiés aux
musiques extrêmes et au métal parmi les
artistes rage behind novelist ou encore
le groupe de bchers rodéo je vous
propose qu'on écoute un
extrait
[Musique]
no organisé par metasos et la batterie
les concerts auront lieu vendredi dans
la salle de la tour à voisin le
Bretonneux et samedi dit à la batterie
de Guy en cour des places sont encore
disponibles et toujours en musique mais
dans un autre style ce weekend Gabriel
c'est la fin du festival Blues sur scène
oui et il vous reste trois dates
Mathilde avant la clôture du festival
vendredi ah HR vous retrouverez les lans
broser samedi soir c'est dirty deep qui
se produira à Limet dernière date
dimanche à 17h à montlaville avec en
première partie Lucy un groupe yvelinois
depuis 24 ans le festival itinérant
blouses sur scène a pour occation de
développer la musique blues dans le moi
depuis sa création plusieurs centaines
d'artistes internationaux et français se
sont produits dans la vallée de la scène
direction Chantelou lesvgne à présent
pour les fantaisies musicales 2023 oui
samedi à 20h l'orchestre classique de
l'alliance se produit au centre
artistique le Phénix de Chantelou lévgne
au programme une soirée de concert avec
pour thème la rencontre de la musique
classique et des valeurs de l'olympisme
engagé et innovant depuis 2017
l'orchestre de l'Alliance propose des
concerts itinérants dans les evelines
objectif partager la musique classique
avec tous les publics même les plus
éloigné après la musique de l'art ce
sont les derniers jours pour profiter de
la 23e bienénale d'art photographique du
chaîné rencour oui et cette année ils
étaient 51 photographes à avoir répondu
présent pour exposer sous forme d'un
quatre images entendez quatre images
cohérentes pour partager une émotion un
souvenir un regard ou un moment dans le
temps pour clôturer l'exposition
photographique qui a lieu tous les 2 ans
le chînero cancour accueille samedi
Olivier Morin reporter photographe à
l'agence France Presse depuis
1990 invité d'honneur de cette édition
il viendra échanger avec les visiteurs
autour d'une conférence et vous
souhaitiez terminer avec une dernière
idée Gabrielle au château de maison la
fite oui pour terminer Mathilde je vous
propose un spectacle immersif pour
redécouvrir le célèbre compte de la
Belle et la Bête pendant 1 heure au
travers d'un parcours spectacle au sein
du château de maison une quinzaine de
scénographies retrac la célèbre histoire
d'amour une parenthèse animée par le jeu
d'une d'une centaine pardon d'acteurs
costumes décor accessoires et musique
l'immersion est complète l'occasion de
savoir s'il vcure vraiment heureux
jusqu'à la fin des temps on regarde la
bande
[Musique]
annonce il y a
quelqu'un je tiens à connaître le visage
de l'homme à qui j'abandonne ma
vie bon et puis pour les plus terre à
terre c'est aussi l'occasion mail de
redécouvrir le château de maison sous un
autre regard et bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toute ces idées